man steht jetzt dort an dem ort und
nehmen die vernichtung hätte stattfinden
sollen
und sie habe es nicht geschafft und wir
sind hier wir machen weiter
ja
das ist meine erste reise im ausschuss
aber natürlich ich habe sehr viele
dokumentarfilme schon gesehen und ich
verstehe was passiert werden
es wird halt sehr emotional werden und
das wird mir sehr interessante gruppen
an unserem guten gefühl geben dass
einfach glaube ich sehr besonders sein
wird und was man vorher auch nicht
wirklich einschätzen
planen kann
[Musik]
es gibt so viele leute die vorstellung
haben dass zum beispiel dem muslime die
juden hassen oder so nein überhaupt
nicht
[Musik]
die gefühle waren wirklich sehr viel
höhere am anfang aber zehn minuten
[Musik]
die besonderheit ist dass wir in so
einer reise die erst einmal an gegen
junge geflüchtete syrien irak die alle
2015 nach deutschland kamen
auf der anderen seiten junge jüdische
erwachsene die auch zum großen teil
migrationshintergrund haben weil sie
juden aus der ehemaligen sowjetunion
sind die sich jetzt gemeinsam auf eine
reise machen auf eine erfahrung dass
nicht zu erleben aber zu hinterfragen
was im zweiten weltkrieg
nationalsozialismus mit den juden
geschehen ist
ihre direkt mittels sohn ihr kennt mich
alle generalsekretären der union
progressiver juden aber auch
vorsitzender der jüdischen gemeinde
bielefeld und ich wünsche uns erst mal
für heute einen guten und
erlebnisreichen tag in krakau
er garantiert viel schöner ist als was
in den nächsten tag erwartet inhaltlich
[Musik]
ich bin halt gespannt auf den austausch
auch tatsächlich weil ich jetzt auch
noch nicht so viel kontakten
flüchtlingen bislang hatte und einfach
gespannt bin auf die lebensgeschichten
und auch noch zugucken wie ihre
erwartungen vielleicht mein sich
überschneiden oder es auch
unterschiedliche vorstellungen gibt da
habe ich einfach gespannt auf den
austausch also ich habe angst dass die
anderen angst haben wegen islamophobie
und außerdem möchte ich die gute seite
von unserem
von unserer religion zeigen also auf
meine art
die wir stets nächste bohrprogramm tech
und 13 uhr einen besuch im islamischen
zentrum
ich hatte mit tiger mit der karriere
gesprochen und da gibt es auch bestimmt
denken diese gelegenheit wird bewegen
möchte im islamischen zentrum des
eingesetzten hoffe und bin sicher dass
wir da auch toiletten putzen gehen weil
das ja auch mal nötig ist
[Musik]
dann müssen die geschichte
also das ist meine erste reise im
ausschuss und natürlich habe ich
wirklich viel erwarten jetzt für
mitgefühl das wäre für mich ein bisschen
kompliziert und schwer aber auf jeden
fall ist es sehr gute erfahrung für eine
person war eine jüdische versorgen das
alles zu verstehen
so wie das gesetz am werk ist
[Musik]
eine führung durch das jüdische krank
wenn nicht dann muss die summe
cacau ist eine besondere stadt die im
zweiten weltkrieg nicht zerstört wurde
das bedeutet alles was wir hier heute
sehen hier in jüdischen vierteln auch in
der altstadt ist alles original erhalten
wenn hier in mitteleuropa
besonders in polen sind ist es wirklich
selten deswegen ein komplett erhaltenes
jüdisches viertel da finden und dazu im
betrieb befindliche sind nach oben und
dazu auch noch einen ganz alten konto
[Musik]
ich finde dass er ein bisschen andere
vor allem die sie formen und auch das
stein ich habe das noch nie gesehen und
es ist ein bleiben immer aber sie blumen
geht weg und ich finde das sehr
interessant
[Musik]
was kommt dann
die die man die mauer mit dem marc stein
ist einfach es ist gar 40 teile die
zusammenbraut und damit die erinnerung
so bleibt und die idee davon in dich
interessant weil ich erst durch wäre und
was noch interessant kann die die graben
unterschiedlich okay das will ich habe
gefragt und die haben mir gesagt
es hängt vom geld ab oder macht so die
leute die mehr geld haben der hat in
krosigk rabenstein
das war ein bisschen ich hatte noch nie
solche sachen wie bei uns die ganzen
leute haben trotz die gleiche graben
große hat spielt keine rolle bei uns
[Musik]
die gespräche sind eigentlich sehr gut
sehr offen und fragt sich viel über die
gepflogenheiten ineinander die
persönliche geschichten wie man dazu
gekommen ist also ist ein sehr nettes
miteinander und sehr schöne gespräche
und man lernt sich gegenseitig kennen
und gut eine gute stimmung
dies wollen wir in den bus einsteigen
und durch die stadt zum teil auch in der
altstadt zum islamischen zentrum fahren
wir werden auf einem parkplatz
aussteigen und noch fünf minuten dahin
laufen müssen
[Musik]
mike war
am 1
das haben wir also arbeit überhaupt
der mann im koma
so zu sehen kann ich schon sehr spannend
wie der kampf anlass zu nehmen
normalerweise beete gerade das mit
aktuell so das kenne ich halt gar nicht
und kann zeit irgendwie faszinierend zu
sehen dass sie gegen den
unterschiedlichen wirkungen aber dann
doch wieder gleichzeitig also da werde
ich gleich in wieder mal nachbestellen
müssen
warum dann die einen timer fährt noch
schneller sind oder es gibt den ich
nicht durchschaut haben aber
gleichzeitig verspannen das sich zum
teil die gewänder in magazins haben das
wäre dann schon eher
zumindest rom gebiet im internet
eingesetzt
allerdings konnte ich jetzt gleich auch
immer nach tagen habe das was von
bedeutung ist quasi für sie hat das du
das sind alles glaube ich gemacht hab
ich gesehen habe
vermerkt ist dass von spiritueller
moment ist für die person also ich hab
dann auch um meine augen geschlossen und
so ein bisschen dazu gehört auch wenn
ich nicht verstanden haben so eine
verbindung kann man da schon also das
finde ich immer dass gebetsraum und das
merkt man auch
also ich find dich schon recht einladen
sowohl
religion zeigt dir wie du mit den
anderen nicht in frieden leben
religion helfe dir in den anderen ein
gutes tablet zu haben und das ist
religion
ich bin nicht sehr religiös ich glaube
unser patient es gibt gerade ich glaube
aber ich mache meine meine gebete
industrien ist
bitte einsteigen bitte einsteigen
[Musik]
an der linken seite sehen sie bilder von
überlebenden die tatsächlich auch die
schindlers liste kam
das bedeutet von hier im jahre 44
evakuiert worden
und es ist ihnen das stimmt bekannt dass
über 90 prozent von polnischen juden im
holocaust gebracht wurden
das bezieht sich auch auf über 90
prozent und kakao jeden waren 45 nicht
mehr darf
[Musik]
zur versorgung der universität wurden zu
einem vortrag eingeladen wenn ein
universitätsgebäude den vortrag gab es
nicht
was war in der fahrer konnte 83 sind
verhaftet worden
und wieder kann man sich fragen wieso
warum verhaftet man die professoren von
einer universität und es geht um
menschen mit hochschulabschluss hatten
eigentlich standen alle mit
hochschulabschluss unter der gefahr
verhaftet zu werden
man man man merkt stelle ähnlichkeit und
tomaten ich hab' ich wusste dass das die
so dass sie verhaftet wurden nicht wegen
religion weil sie hat gesagt die die
professoren und professoren das bedeutet
dass wir doch bildung und deswegen sie
wurden verhaftet und ich wusste das weil
ich ich weiß dass auch solche leute bei
uns verhaftet würden verstecken war eine
komplizierte prozedur
folglich wurden menschen in schränken in
mission in google monate lang versteckt
was wir uns heute gar nicht vorstellen
können unter welchen umständen und das
ohne zu wissen wann und ob es zu ende
geht
das war alles illegal also gewiss luxor
nach
wir müssen nur nachts fliegen
wir dürften zum beispiel nicht in der
öffentlichkeit gehen dass in der türkei
weil wir sind ja ohne pc bekommen und
das schlimmste von allen war dass wir
mit dem schlauchboot für erhalten die
nach griechenland gefahren sind und ja
das ist also keine schöne erinnerung auf
englisch
das ich jetzt führe dies erfahren
falls jemand an einer stelle zum schluss
kommt ihr verkraftet er es nicht mehr
dann bitte mir mich damit ich ihnen
bescheid sagen kann diese hier aus dem
museum kaum
wollte ein bisschen von dieser
atmosphäre bisschen raus ich frage mich
immer warum also menschen machen mit
einem anderen menschen so wir sind alle
menschen egal
die religion und hautfarbe oder so also
ich verstehe das wirklich nicht wieso
solche menschen mit anderen menschen so
machen
ja also ich habe schon mit ein paar
leute konnte muslimischen teil
gesprochen
aber meine meinung nach dass sie
verstehen nicht 100 prozentig weil
manche leute ich habe nur einfach fotos
gemacht wie auf einer reise eine urlaub
zum beispiel ja aber manchen verstehen
das auch
die jüdische jugendliche gruppe die es
gibt vier fünf jugendliche denen man was
in meinem alter sind die waren nicht so
aktiv
sie haben kein kleinen interesse kritik
oder gezeigt so ich habe mich gestern
beschwerden wegen das weil okay wir sind
hier um austausch wir wollen austausch
in diesem wichtigen ort und ich habe
mich gestern mich werden wir haben auch
ein bisschen diskutieren es hat geklappt
wir haben das von gestern gelernt es ist
nicht wichtig dass ich jede einzelne
zahl im kopf behalten sondern dass sich
diese dimension also diese größe
begreife was hier passiert ist und
bittet euch nicht eva und eva zu fragen
auch wenn ihr meinen wir können das
nicht aber sie können es auch manchmal
mit deutschen kindern anders machen oder
fragt epi fragte immer fragt mich sagt
ein schafft ja ok
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist für manche von ihnen natürlich
dass sie sehr bekannte aufnahme dieser
situation zwei colón der menschen wie
serien jetzt diese bekannteste band der
eingangstore das ist der originale
wir sehen weiter dieser rampe zwei
kolonnen menschen eine reihe männer und
die frauen
wie sehen es als der diesen menschen
nach lebens reaktion
das ging ganz dem gaskammer und das ist
wie gesagt das ist fast 700 meter und
dass man die kammer thorium nummer zwei
und nummer 37 gehen dass die nicht in
anspruch oder abend zum bad zum duschen
gehen das war die ganze zeit beruhigte
[Musik]
solchen soldaten damals form haben warum
haben sie den juden gesagt ihr geht
jetzt duschen sie nicht gesagt er werde
jetzt gleich umgebracht nochmals es geht
über ganze zeigen beruhigung system es
geht über eventuelle revolte wäsche auf
ein paar minuten vor dem tod machten
diese zum tode verurteilten durchführen
und deshalb habe nicht wie wie kann das
machen fiel sofort an dieser rampe jetzt
wie 2000 3000 menschen ein paar deutsche
soldaten sagen jetzt alle gehen zum tod
zu der gaskammer und was ist passiert
sind moment ruhig
warum haben sie nicht gemacht juden
damals wenn es so wenn sie sagen ja es
waren nur wenige soldaten
die sind sowieso tut es war generell
nicht so viele soldaten bestimmt aber
diese leute eingesperrt war dann in
diesem wagen viele tage waren eben diese
zahl jetzt haben keine chance haben auch
manche reporter durchgeführt aber ohne
chance ohne möglichkeiten
zahl abhören geht über auschwitz das ist
mehr als 1.100.000 wenn durchgeführt
wurde diese sorge vernichtungsaktion
dann diese aktion war perfekt
vorbereitet
[Applaus]
achso osteuropäischen politisch
gesprochen für die herstellung aus
polnisch deutsch und hebräisch und ein
bisschen die schrift ist auf 80 90
prozent der wirte sind in
mittelhochdeutsch und ich habe das
gesehen die haben fast deutsch
gesprochen ja aber das war nicht genau
ich habe mich gewundert was das von
einer sprache entwickelt was interessant
ist dass diese sprache auf hebräisch
noch stadion geschehen würde und was
sagen die gelernt haben
die bibel gelesen und die bibel ist also
könnten sie das alles bild und deswegen
haben sie auch endlich in diesem buch
sterben müssten
[Musik]
das sperma die brache
wir haben mehrere junge hat israel ist
man kariwa mentoren mit marcel wita
davita levitan als mythischer leila mink
olbia tage später mata der am iran palma
wie moet chandon markus rall kolben
herdam dem rahmen
ja also es ist schon irgendwie hartz
bezug zu gestern abend nicht und das ist
glaube ich gerade dann spannen dass wir
tatsächlich erstmal versuchen über das
gebet
dazu gehört zu bekommen ich glaube wir
keine ahnung nach kann ich gut darüber
sprechen
jetzt ist ja auch lehnt einen ganz
anderen eindruck wenn man dann genau da
steht wo letztendlich die menschen
umgebracht worden sind und das ist das
was man gerade auch einen punkt
ich habe schon informationen über
auschwitz und hat es hier willkommen
aber ich habe niemals die gelegenheit
das vorstellen genau und ich finde das
wirklich furchtbar weil heute das sehr
überreichte wir sind da das ist doch
nicht nur essen oder dokumente oder das
ist die bereiche system
ich finde ich gar nicht mehr ab seit 1
ich finde dich nicht die wörter es ist
sehr kompliziert das zu verstehen wenn
man das sieht man wenn man diese
beispiele rat vor seine augen natürlich
fühle ich natürlich traurig aber ich
habe auch viele denken in meinem kopf
also das erste bin sehr froh dass sie
jetzt ich kann ich leben darf also jetzt
haben wir keinen krieg und natürlich wir
sind eigentlich hier zusammen ich meine
deutsche das leben florian die
nationalität sind und jetzt wir haben
keine probleme miteinander zu reden
wurde etwas zu verteilen
es gibt keine konflikte zwischen uns der
für die nächste erfahren
bist du einfach einer von millionen die
sterben du bist einfach läuft dir und
denkst du bist ja niemand mit einer
nummer
du bist gar nicht mehr recht auf wohnen
die mit namen angesprochen dann noch den
grund hast zu lied das zu überleben denn
vorstellen
ich glaube es ist schlimmer wenn du
weisst nicht ob du stellst du schaukelt
zwischen leben und sterben
die ganze zeit das macht mich verrückt
ich kam nach birkenau im sommer 1943
meine name vorname wasser auch deutsche
fans
ich kam im sommer 43 nach birkenau
medikament laufen der nummer laufen der
nummer ich war hier block 17 hirt und
dann es war der große unterschied die
juden wurden in dieser zeit hier nach
zehn tagen ungefähr da waren die juden
hier selektioniert und kann man in die
gaskammer dagegen wir alle häftlinge die
willkommen zu diesem baracken in
bielefeld kam ich für seine apotheke und
der apotheke hat sie gemerkt hat dieses
nummer gemerkt und sie haben gesagt ach
ja da haben sie eine nummer
ich habe auch eine nummer und denn meine
nummer bekomme ich hier also das war das
war ein ss mann hast ja sehr sagt naja
also sind sie sich hier sind kollegen
die sind kollegen
ich habe ihnen gesagt na ja sagt zeitung
ich komme muss muss er seine an der
apotheke
wieso haben sie es nicht weg lasern
lassen oder weg das ist ziemlich
interessante frage also in polen ist
dieser nummer kann es keine schande
darüber hinaus ließ
genau sie sind ja als widerstandskämpfer
quasi inhaftiert worden
wie haben sie diese entscheidung
getroffen da war ich werde ihm das
klinge aber wie haben sie die
entscheidung getroffen in den widerstand
zu gehen sie hätten ja auch einfach zu
hause sitzen bleiben können und sehen
sie dass ich die lager der polen das war
die schlimmste zeit alle anderen völker
und der deutscher besatzung
das war die schlimmste zeit konnte man
mit den mit den nazis damals auch sagen
das ist ein verbrechen für sie machen
oder konnte man das nicht sagen
sehen sie unter den ss leuten es war
manches ist ein selten sehr selten
die fetten 1 1 mitleid zu gehabt zu den
juden aber es war sehr selten
das ist antwort auf ihre frage noch mal
ganz ganz herzlich dass sie den weithin
bekannten
herzlichen dank eine gute rückreise der
wünschen er im judentum max althoff
alles gute weiterhin bis 120 ich bin
überrascht ich also also wie schwer das
war weil es eine 92 jahre alt und
trotzdem erinnert alles und antwortet
auf alles und er also wenn man so alt
ist und erinnert das alles das war sehr
schwer für ihn und also ich bin echt
beeindruckend und also und fand ich
schon dass er sehr leben freudig und fwg
vergibt und so das hatte jeden treffen
können auch gerade die erzählungen die
ihr von einer person die die sich
entschieden hat quasi sich zum
staatsfeind zu machen oder zum feind der
nazis dadurch dass sie den widerstand
gegangen ist dass diese personen dort
auch sind genauso wie wie die juden die
irgendwie durch ihre herkunft oder
geburt der feind oder der feind in
anführungsstrichen sind ich glaube
dadurch hat man hat das so die gruppe
noch zusammen getan dass man gesagt hat
wahrscheinlich würden die nazis heute
auch keinen unterschied mehr machen
zwischen unseren beiden gruppen
[Musik]
weil wir sozusagen ein bisschen
schüchtern voneinander und so aber ja
heute habe wer also mehr voneinander
gelernt mehr miteinander gesprochen und
so ja und auch also diesem moment wenn
wir die kerzen angemacht haben ja also
das war wie er was gesagt hat also
menschlicher moment egal welche religion
jetzt ist und so ja war sehr emotionaler
moment
also können wir alle gern erde treffen
[Applaus]
wissen wohin
aber
[Musik]
sein
erstmals stehen wir als vertreter einer
deutsch muslimischen
religionsgemeinschaft stehe ich an
diesem ort des schreckens dem
konzentrations und vernichtungslager
auschwitz dieser ort des
unbeschreiblichen menschlichen leids ist
ein furchterregendes symbol für die
entrechtung entmenschlichung und
verfolgung von millionen menschen
für den von deutschen begangenen
zivilisationsbruch der shoa
man kann eigentlich nicht wollen diesen
ort zu besuchen
und dennoch haben wir uns als muslime
aufgemacht zusammen mit unseren
jüdischen freunden diesen ort zu
besuchen weil man diesen ort besuchen
muss um wenigstens zu versuchen zu
verstehen welche verantwortung wir heute
und in der zukunft zu tragen haben im
gedenken an das verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit an die unzähligen toten
die hier unermessliches leid erfahren
mussten lege ich eine rose des friedens
und des erinnerns nieder
ich trage sie vor gehüllt in einen
besonderen teil liegt ein gebet mantel
der einem überlebenden insassen von
auschwitz gehört ariel benmosche mit
lora leo weinheber hat auschwitz in
diesem tag überlebt und hatte mir für
diesen anlass geborgt als symbol für das
was wir hier sind wir leben und sie sind
nicht mehr
wir könnten schweigen natürlich auch
schweizer antwort aber dann würden wir
sie wahrscheinlich zum zweiten mal töten
ich nehme an da ich ähnliche programme
kenne das ihr überflutet wurde von
einzuhalten eine grauenhafte als die
andere zahlen die undenkbar sind bilder
die man nicht fassen kann
ihr müsst euch ein bisschen anstrengen
und ein bisschen fantasie entwickeln die
der brennpunkt eure kamera linse etwas
auf nach einstellung bringt und immerzu
vorstellen dass es um eine geliebte
person aus ihrer direkten nähe handelt
eine mutter ein vater ein bruder eine
schwester ein teurer freund sie hier
gequält und getötet und sind möge dieser
anlass wenn ich das so sagen darf
gesegnet sein
gesegnet dadurch dass ihr die jungen
leute hier versammelt tief beeindruckt
bin ich dass es moslems und juden
zusammen sind
aber habe die gleiche aufgabe es ist
wurscht wie ihr seid die lektion ist die
gleiche und wenn es sie nicht in der
eigenen gesellschaft oder in der
gesellschaft überall verwirklicht dann
war das nur ein touristischer besuch
das soll es nicht gewesen sein so möge
gottes üben
an der ehrung
einfach zu zeigen dass wir bei allen
unterschieden einfach gemeinsam bereits
und für unsere zukunft einzustehen und
dort etwas zu bewirken irgendwie als
vorbild vielleicht auch voran und gehen
dann ist doch auch andere leute jetzt
sehen irgendwie und vielleicht auch
weitere initiativen einverstanden weil
es einfach wichtig genau zu sagen auch
nicht immer nur die unterschiede zu tun
sondern einfach von vornherein zu sagen
da ist also eine gemeinsamkeit und dann
sehen wir weiter
ich komme auch aus dem krieg und ich
habe verwandte die gestorben sind und so
und natürlich fühle ich dieses gefühl
also es tut mir echt leid ich glaube
auch dass es richtig ist dass politiker
dabei sind und politikerinnen es darf
natürlich nicht nur ein symbol bleiben
also es ist leicht irgendwo ein kranz
niederzulegen
das muss auch in die tat umgesetzt
müssen ganz klar es muss ganz klar gegen
sich gegen antisemitismus positioniert
werden egal aus welcher
gesellschaftsschicht auch gegen
islamophobie den jegliche form von
diskriminierung und es dürfen nicht nur
leere worthülsen bleiben und grenze bei
an die toten gedenken ist relativ
einfach und man muss taten folgen lassen
auch für die auch für die lebenden
es gab viel aufmerksamkeit auf ein
politiker auch die presse ist nicht ein
bisschen auch ich man steht und auf
einmal ein kleinerer hervor der das das
ärgert ist natürlich ist etwas gutes
dass auch wichtige leute dabei zu sein
ok damit man mehr fokus und unser ziel
ich hoffe ja vielleicht nachher können
wir ein bisschen unser gefühl der mehr
teilen unter uns einander und unser
meinungen
ich habe die gruppe ausgesprochen
positiv auch erlebt dass sie schon
zusammengewachsen sind auch durch die
tage die sie schon miteinander verbracht
haben wir hatten auch schon
vorbereitungstreffen
also es war keine gruppenbildung mehr
sondern es war wirklich eine gemeinsame
gruppe von muslimischen und jüdischen
jugendlichen und jungen erwachsenen und
sie haben ja auch hier ein besonderes
erlebnis in auschwitz das alles so zu
erleben ist ja auch noch mal eine
besondere belastung aber das haben wie
finde ich gut aufgenommen und von daher
merke ich schon dass dieses projekt
einen sehr guten sinn hat das lager was
wir gesehen haben
das hat mich erinnert das
flüchtlingslager das in jordanien gibt
oder als auch die türkei gibt es waren
auch nicht so schrecklich oder haben den
ich jetzt in jordanien das den tod
gewartet aber auf den gott gewartet aber
also schlechte lebensbedingungen zeigen
also wenn man das nur auf fernsehfilm
autofenster kommentare finma sieht oder
die büchenbach ii fließen das ist ganz
andere gefühle als man das selbst sehen
darf es ist unmöglich selbst zu
verstehen natürlich alle war traurig
manche haben geweint aber ich hoffe das
sehr gute sehr gute experience bewusst
diese jungen leute sind eingeladen
gewesen über einen längeren prozess sich
mit deutscher geschichte
auseinanderzusetzen weil wir der meinung
sind es ist notwendig dass wir menschen
die bei uns leben auch unsere geschichte
erklären und vor allem unsere
verantwortung zu der geschichte so weit
bin ich dankbar dass die jungen menschen
sich aufgemacht haben diesen weg zu
gehen und damit zeichen zu setzen und
wenn jetzt die verbände in dem fall die
union der progressiven juden und der
zentralrat der muslime dieses in
deutschland noch mehr machen sollten wir
als bundesländer das stark unterstützen
[Musik]
michael c
ja
sein
ist ein 2
[Musik]
rhein main
zeit
[Musik]